[Music]
on this tuesday night election deja vu
pretty much a political status quo as
the liberals failed to win the majority
they were seeking this was
the most pointless election in in
canada's history what the liberals
gained and lost plus what the outcome
means for the future of the leaders and
the country
and some reflections on why voting is
vital even if it doesn't result in much
change
the jason kenny effect on the federal
conservatives i think it played a
significant role howatory blew alberta
voted this time as its unpopular premier
shuffles his cabinet
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is all over none of the parties got
what they wanted and now canadians are
left wondering whether the federal
election changes anything in the months
ahead though some races are still too
close to call it is clear justin
trudeau's liberals did win enough seats
to form a second minority government the
seat count is almost identical to last
time this is 2019
and this is 2021. some ballots still
need to be counted but the numbers and
the makeup of parliament is almost
exactly what it was before
yet justin trudeau calls it a clear
mandate
some have talked about division
but that's not what i see you are
sending us back to work
with a clear mandate to get canada
through this pandemic and to the
brighter days ahead
that was last night today trudeau was
out thanking voters in his riding he
didn't hold any media briefing though
conservative aaron o'toole did answer
questions today he admitted he is
disappointed the tories didn't make more
gains but says he is ready for next time
i'm the leader of the party that founded
this great country and i'm very proud of
that i want to earn that trust of
canadians and that's why we're going to
work tirelessly
to examine what went right what went
wrong
the ndp's jagmeet singh also failed to
win as many seats as he'd hoped but will
return to ottawa holding the balance of
power and in a position of influence
we were the most successful opposition
party in the last parliament and this
parliament looks pretty much the same
and we'll continue to do the work that
we did before so canadians can rest
assured we'll be there for them
saskatchewan's premier today spoke about
the election and voiced what a lot of
canadians are probably feeling
this was
the most pointless election in in
canada's history the prime minister
spent over six hundred million dollars
of
your dollars taxpayer dollars and five
weeks further dividing the country to
arrive at
almost the same result that we had two
months ago in the house of commons
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson watched this all play out with
us last night mercedes justin trudeau
framing this result as a clear mandate
for the future does anyone outside of
his inner circle believe that
i don't think that canadians are buying
that and they clearly sent that message
in the polls they said yes we're giving
you a mandate to govern but it's the
same election result essentially as we
saw in 2019. canadians are comfortable
with the leader the liberals leading and
they want them to do that but they want
the checks and balances of other parties
in place this was a 600 million dollar
election essentially for a couple of
seats and very divisive rhetoric on the
campaign trail for essentially the same
result what the liberals are trying to
spin this as is saying they needed the
moral authority to govern with big
picture programs things like 10 a day
child care a bold environmental plan and
coveted recovery but the reality is all
of those programs were actually
introduced in the last parliament they
had the ndp on side in fact if anything
the ndp wanted them to go further so
trying to argue they needed to go to the
pool so they could do these things i'm
not sure that people are going to buy
into that and they're in the same
situation now with parliament they have
to work with other parties one senior
liberal said to me well you know we're
in a more secure situation though now
because no one's going to want another
election well i think it's a little hard
to argue anyone other than justin
trudeau and the liberals wanted this
election
no party got what they wanted last night
what might this mean for the future of
justin trudeau of aaron o'toole and judd
meat singh
well for justin trudeau you know he's
very popular in the liberal party but
this was the first election where we saw
his personal brand actually becoming
problematic in polling that people felt
that this was an election he called
about him because he wanted power they
saw it as a power grab so he went from
being the golden boy the liberal party
to a potential risk will he run in
another election
one senior liberal said to me who knows
people's circumstances change that's not
something you would have heard after a
previous election aaron o'toole though
much more difficult road ahead there's
going to be a huge fight inside the
party about whether it was a mistake to
move towards the center and they should
have gone
and stayed where they were on the right
with the ppc vote jug meet singh
underperformed in terms of the number of
seats that he won however he will be in
a power position in parliament and that
may help to protect him donna all right
lots to watch for mercedes stevenson
thank you
the challenge for the liberals is to
make parliament work with the help of
the other parties and actually deliver
on the promises they made they did make
gains in alberta that might help build
some bridges there here's abigail beeman
let us feel the warmth of a new dawn a
new dawn
or groundhog day we're right back where
we started
we got the same results
although although it was a draw on the
federal treasury of 610 million dollars
and meant a lot of us had to wait in
line to vote your worst day in governing
is uh better than your best day in
opposition so yeah this is a win
absolutely maybe not the full win that
they wanted
but it is a win i hear you when you say
that you just want to get back to the
things you love
not worry about this pandemic
or about an election after railing
against the opposition for getting in
the way during the last minority
government how exactly will the liberals
move forward with another minority
mandate this is the way it is in
politics and the prime minister is going
to make his best case that this is
indeed what he wanted to happen after
all
but he's going to have to deal with some
opposition parties and he's got to prove
to canadians that he can make parliament
work the biggest losses for liberals
look like three cabinet ministers down
in ontario minister for women gender
equality and rural economic development
marian monsef and seniors minister deb
schult and in nova scotia fisheries
minister bernadette jordan having three
women
cabinet ministers lose is
particularly not very good the liberals
had some interesting pickups too a gta
seat stolen back from floor crosser
leona alislev and looks like two seats
in alberta where they had been shut out
completely in 2019 pundits and partisans
will argue about winners and losers and
which heads should roll or stay attached
for the moment let's give the last word
to the trudeau matriarch i'm so proud of
him
he kept the high road he
never he kept being kind
perhaps save for this moment isn't there
a hospital you should be going to bother
right now broadly speaking trudeau did
not engage in personal attacks in an
election many will see as a personal
referendum on his leadership
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the governing liberals will need the
support of the ndp to get some things
done like passing a budget jugmeet singh
didn't win as many seats as he wanted
but he will still wield some power
getting his agenda on the table here's
robin gill
donna jugmeet singh looked dejected and
disappointed when he held his postmortem
news conference the party will obviously
have to dissect what went wrong but
singh insists he'll stay at the helm of
the n.g.p
jagmeet singh is carrying the weight of
a party that wanted to send more new
democrats to ottawa it's a loss not just
for me as a leader and not just for new
democrats as a team but it's a loss for
canada some of these really incredible
candidates that would have really made a
big difference
this is the second election for singh
and despite his personal popularity it
hasn't translated into votes for the ndp
party insiders say it takes time to
build up a leader if canadians over
overwhelmingly have a positive
impression of mr singh then
that's a good thing that's that's where
you start and then it's the the next
phase which is to look at somebody and
see them yeah this could be our prime
minister yes we do thank you so much the
ndp spent 25 million dollars on this
campaign yo bro who got you smiling like
that like much of it on a social media
strategy aimed at a younger electorate
that didn't turn out as hoped this
political scientist says the ndp leader
was all style and no substance tell me
what the content was in the ndp platform
this time
a lot about his
a lot about
i'm not the other guys
and then a bunch of promises that
no one could take seriously singh spoke
to justin trudeau to congratulate him
but says there wasn't an opportunity to
negotiate his priorities which include a
national pharmacare and dental plan he
still believes that he's in a position
to fight for those issues despite being
a fourth place party when the
opportunity comes donna all right robin
gill in vancouver thanks erin o'toole
also failed to deliver what he was going
for he lost and the conservatives have
fewer seats now than they did in the
last election he leads a divided party
politically and geographically o'toole
said today he wants to learn from what
happened last night here's mike likatura
with his family in tow erin o'toole
returned to ottawa with nearly the same
number of mps and nearly the same
questions the last leader faced in 2019.
how can he consider this a win and how
can he stay on as conservative party
leader we also didn't win the trust
to a level we needed in parts of the gta
some parts of the country that we have
to do better
that's why we're going to undertake a
review to make sure we learn the lessons
at last count the o'toole conservatives
won fewer seats than in 2019. one-third
of elected conservatives are from
saskatchewan and alberta a place where
support was down from the last election
we can expect those
mps to
to take issue with the kind of campaign
that he ran which is you know trying to
move the party to the center make it
look much more like an old progressive
conservative party still some in the
party say that move to the middle is
essential if the conservatives want to
form government again when you sacrifice
votes in the west to gain more votes in
in the east and
at the end of the day we're in a
situation where you know we might have
to do that the conservative party
constitution stipulates a leadership
review is triggered if they don't form
government after an election andrew
scheer was pressured to step aside but
some feel o'toole shouldn't suffer that
same fate when you lose a couple in a
row people get restless the question
again i ask myself is is we've got so
much invested in mr o'toole in a
minority parliament
you know probably best to let him have
another crack at this if you think
o'toole's comments and commitment to a
review process sound familiar it's
because they are
andrew scheer said the same things in
2019 and was forced to step down two
months later
donna all right michael couture thanks
the green party's future looks
precarious leader enemy paul failed to
win her toronto riding putting her
political future in doubt the party also
got a lower percentage of the popular
vote this time but as mike charlay
reports the greens are still sending two
mps to ottawa and scored their first
election win in ontario
there's no asterisk in politics you
either win or lose in the end it doesn't
matter how you got there you call it a
lucky break or whatever but
it worked out newly elected green party
mp mike morris's road to electoral
victory opened up when liberal incumbent
raj saney dropped out of the race amid
accusations of inappropriate behavior
towards his female staff which he denied
yeah i'm not concerned with any
asterisks i'm doing this to be a voice
for my neighbors in ottawa morris along
with elizabeth may are the only greens
going to ottawa after a turmoil filled
election this wasn't a good night for
the greens um and it wasn't a good night
for enemy paul
where to start how about with the
internal squabbles that consumed the
party for the better part of the year
at the center of it party leader enemy
paul who finished a distant fourth not
nationally she finished fourth in her
toronto center riding it is hard to lose
no one likes to lose under paul the
party failed to field a candidate in 86
ridings and didn't release its core
platform on climate until two weeks ago
there's a lot to analyze i wouldn't want
to just give an off-the-cuff answer but
i'm not surprised because
we usually are
much better organized in advance and
really have a strong efforts to engage
that could be seen as a swipe at paul
who only campaigned outside her riding
four times during the election
now her party of two is facing a
leadership review i think it's too early
to say that the greens have no future
but
i think they're going to have to have
some tough conversations about uh you
know what that future's going to look
like and what they're going to do to do
better next time and whether there'll be
a next time for anime paul
microlight global news toronto
the cracks in conservative support
coming up was alberta's unpopular
premier a liability for aaron o'toole
alberta is in a state of turmoil not
only has premier jason kenney shuffled
his health minister out of that role
he's asked for the federal government to
help manage the record number of covid19
patients and the shortage of critical
care staff premier kenny is deeply
unpopular in alberta how he handled the
crisis played out in the final days of
the federal election campaign and it may
have affected the tory vote in 2019 the
federal conservatives received 69
percent of the popular vote in alberta
this time that dropped to 55 percent and
the covid crisis isn't over alberta has
more than 20 000 active cases and almost
a thousand people in the hospital as
jamie dahl reports some in kenny's own
cabinet want him out
alberta is sending a liberal to ottawa
and he's from calgary splintering the
solid blue canvas once sprawling over
the heartland of conservative country
we've got to put partisanship to the
side and focus on delivering for our
for our city and province the tories
grip easing some in edmonton with two
new democrats heading to ottawa while
the bulk of alberta mps are still cpc
support is starting to sag some wasting
no time pointing the finger of blame
squarely at the premier and his handling
of the pandemic i think it played a
significant role i don't know how you
can look at a at a federal conservative
campaign that increased its popular vote
that picked up seats outside of alberta
and lost seats within alberta without
looking at the effect that the premier
had and the connection between the
o'toole team and
and the provincial government aaron
o'toole refused to even mention jason
kenney by name during his campaign the
premier's popularity has plummeted and
there are even calls for a leadership
review from members in his own party as
the province battles another deadly
fourth wave i believe that the
leadership in this province has been
wanting it's been all over the map and
inconsistent it's clear that uh
albertans
and party members cannot trust him on
tuesday afternoon kenny decided to shake
things up swapping out his health
minister the timing no coincidence but
this political analyst says the federal
election results are not why having
stuck with the health minister for this
long and only replacing him on the eve
of a caucus meeting that is rumored to
have a non-confidence motion at it
really does suggest that the premier is
throwing minister chandra under the bus
in an attempt to save his own career
there is another factor that could have
weakened tory support in alberta while
they didn't win a seat the people's
party of canada got a little over 7
percent of the popular vote here
further proof of a shift in a province
often reluctant to change
jamie dahl global news edmonton
ahead how monday's vote paints another
clear picture of canada's stark
divisions
the outcome of the federal election
exposed a sharp divide in this country
prime minister trudeau's political
gamble didn't get him the majority he
wanted and was an unpopular move among
many canadians the outcome appears to
have changed little but it did stoke
anger here's eric sorenson
donna this is what the house of commons
looked like at disillusion and after
yesterday's election so far it looked
like this
you could be forgiven for not seeing
much difference mr trudeau was hoping
for a quick power grab it wasn't the
most gracious concession but aaron
o'toole's reaction fueled by that
election outcome underscores the
divisions in the country canadians sent
him back with another minority at the
cost of 600 million dollars and deeper
divisions in our great country some have
talked about division
but that's not what i see the prime
minister was already trying to move on
but the campaign wounds and barbs are
still fresh six years of mr trudeau mr
o'toole you're wrong mr trudeau and mr
o'toole teamed up the divisions
reflected in a campaign that was often
uncivil
the divide is striking often acrimonious
between conservatives and liberals
between east and west you can see that
on the map and between urban and rural
look at the makeup of the biggest cities
in vancouver mostly liberal reds some
ndp orange montreal laval a perpetual
liberal stronghold and toronto and the
surrounding communities the so-called
liberal fortress ever expanding while
larger rural ridings in blue and some
large swaths of the country are just as
solidly anchored to their conservative
roots the frustration for conservatives
there are more urban voters with
progressive views on issues from climate
to guns the liberals have shown once
again that they're able to to appeal to
the urban vote but rural canada very
much still remains within the
conservative realm that's a cleavage
that i think all political parties are
taking stock of right now i want to
congratulate the prime minister on his
re-election as prime minister of canada
thud is the way drug meat sings
congratulations may have landed with his
supporters but it was civil and it's a
start trudeau would like the ill will to
go away now i hear you when you say that
you just want to get back to the things
you love
not worry about this pandemic
or about an election he was the first to
want this election and seemingly the
first who wants to put it behind him
eric sorensen global news toronto
next some reflections on the right to
vote
there is a shared sentiment today that
this country just went to the polls for
nothing candidates campaigned during a
pandemic and canadians ended up with
virtually the same political
representation we had before it is
understandable that people are miffed
but voting is a right we shouldn't take
for granted mike armstrong gives us some
context
there was a time when we couldn't do
this
well people like me could white
landowning men really haven't had much
trouble voting through history but the
lineups at polling stations would have
looked very different if you went back
through time before 1960 first nations
couldn't vote without giving up their
indian status before 1950 the inuit
couldn't vote asian canadians didn't get
the right to vote until 1948 and if you
went back to 1917 basically half of the
entire country women couldn't vote
so back to today
it's a right that's easy to take for
granted and a lot of us do votes are
still being counted so the final voter
turnout still isn't known but it's not
good it may be just under 60 percent
which would make it the worst voter
turnout in a federal election ever
during this election the world watched
an entire country lose the right to vote
women or men there will be no visits to
a ballot box in afghanistan for the
foreseeable future no more fingers died
to show they'd just cast a vote and had
literally put their lives on the line
showing up to do it well they wish they
had our problems done in afghanistan
elections aren't easy they're bitter and
they're not cheap at 600 million they're
really not cheap but we might want to
avoid saying they don't have any value
even one word feels like no one got what
they wanted it's kind of fun and it
feels accurate to shrug our shoulders
and say all that for this
well maybe we're pretty much the same
country we were in 2019 maybe most of us
still feel pretty much the same way and
support the same people we did then it
feels like we've got the proof
so maybe we should try not to take that
expression of the will of the people for
granted and considering the brutal year
and a half we've all just had the fact
we're not more divided
may be a good sign
mike armstrong global news montreal
and that's global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]